[MUSIC PLAYING]
Store locators are among the
most popular applications built
today using Google Maps API.
Whether you're building a
site to help customers find
the nearest store
or book a hotel,
your application needs a place
to store and query location
data.
That's where a Google
Cloud Platform can help.
By building your application
using Google Cloud's SQL
and App Engine, you
can scale your maps
to millions of customers.
No need to buy and maintain your
own infrastructure, hardware,
or software.
For developers looking to
migrate their store locators
to Google's cloud, we've created
a helpful guide that shows you
how to, one, create a cloud
SQL database table, two,
perform geospatial
queries, and three,
visualize the data using
GeoJSON and our APIs.
We also have a sample
code library in Python
to help you quickly get started.
For access to these tools,
take a look at our blog.